this is a production of cornell
university
so then i arrived at driscolls and
driscoll's
sustainability was kind of new then
and i learned quite a bit about
agriculture i knew more about forests
um then but you know there's still
plants still managed
ecosystems even more managed than boris
you know extra level there
um and i fell in love with the industry
that
fed us
you know that been humans
and that connection between food
and ecosystems and nature
environment and i
and that's um so fast forward now i am
the director of sustainability at the
national fresh producers association
and
what is great about my job today is that
i see
all of the crops
so from avocados to lettuce to
strawberries
to flowers of course
and
but there are many common themes in in
what we work in sustainability so what i
want to talk to you about is
how do we define sustainability in this
industry
so
we're not reinventing the wheel
we let the un do that for us and then so
we follow the
the united nations um
sustainable development goals
to
form our programs i hope that many of
you are
familiar with uh
them
so what is sustainability is the triple
bottom line so
people planet profit
and in our research uh the younger
generations have trouble with the word
profit
and so do i
um i prefer
you know thriving then profitability um
it seems but that's the way it is
defined
by the industry today and those are the
three principles by which
we form
our programs and most sustainability
programs
everywhere
our definition of sustainability is the
optimization of processes and resources
in order to drive social environmental
and economic benefits leave the world a
better place for future
generations
so thinking of today
and tomorrow always as as part of the
framework
i said i was going to talk about
inspiration so as an association with
our members
what we do is
we inspire them we advocate for them and
we we don't do research but we support
research for the industry and i'll talk
about it later
um
inspiration
they need inspiration
to
learn more about what sustainability is
to work on better practices in the field
and we advocate
um
representing the industry because
believe it or not
um
in the governmental world
very few people really understand
produce most people think that
agriculture
is
corn or soy
props you have
one person in a tractor and you know
acres and makers and makers and acres
or livestock which is a whole different
ballgame
but purpose is very different
produces
tiny tails
lots of people lots and lots and lots of
people picking those
those
those fruits or vegetables so the social
aspect of our industry is huge compared
to other um agricultural sectors
and also our reliance on
plastic
is immense as well and that's what
sets us apart from other agricultural
industries
also because we're smaller fields
we might not be
so impactful in the area of
deforestation which is what you hear all
the time
30 percent
of climate change
comes from agriculture but wait a second
what kind of agriculture
and so
in produce we have an opportunity to
speak our voice and talk about our the
nuances of our industry
even if diverse because you can't really
compare avocados with lips but
we try we try
and so
how do we try to do that in
sustainability so we separate
sustainability in
seven focus areas so coming from that
way
the un
sustainable development goals
bring it into produce what's core and
produce for sustainability so these
seven focus areas and i'm going to go a
little bit in detail about what each one
of them is and then i do hope that you
have a lot of questions
number one
i want to not be
packaging it's huge we're very very
dependent on packaging
and um
i think that it's safe for all of us
that we currently in our society
detest
plastic
but we're dependent on it and so is our
industry
our industry needs that plastic in the
field to grow the crops he needs the
plastic sometimes in the packaging to
get it from the field to the
to the consumer
and sometimes that packaging it's so
needed because otherwise you would lose
a lot of that you know that a lot of the
fruit will brought you you will have
food waste but you don't want to so
it's an evil that is we're dependent on
that equal and then when we talk about
packaging
we talk about single-use plastic
reduction
tough one
recycling
as many of you probably know only about
eight to nine percent of the plastic in
the united states is recycled so
recyclability is i would say it's
basically an urban legend it's really
hard to get plastic recycled for a
number of reasons
composting
you know a packaging that becomes
a compost and it's compostable that is
the kind of the new frontier that's why
i put it with that kind of letter there
um and then system design
because who says we have to sell and
plastic
maybe we could rethink things and so
system design is very important to
address
our packaging issue
and then
food waste and food loss
maybe in your school today you're not
thinking a lot about food waste and food
loss
but in the field and the industry it's
it's huge
so in the field we're losing um
a lot of the
part of the crop and so that we would
call it normally food loss that's before
it reaches a distribution center and in
the distribution center because what
happens
more
food is lost that we call it food waste
um what happens there is that we deal
with quality issues
parents
some of them are
are not safe to be in a container they
can be shipped
they're in the rank etc
and so
about
10
of the
is lost there at the distribution center
and then
there are more losses when it reaches
the
retailer because it could be days after
it was at the distribution center right
you know by the time you said the
retailer could be
four days on a truck
and so at the retailer they're
discarding a lot of fruits and
vegetables that are not suitable for
consumption
so you have more waste there so
what do you do with that
whole mess
so there are a different number of
solutions
all the food loss on the on the field
the solutions are normally technical or
agronomical so the type of agronomy you
use
could change you could improve
um
quality you could improve
the flavor etc
also different technologies that
could be used in the field to prolong
the life of that
of the problem
and then once it's in the distribution
center at the retailer lots of things
happen with the food waste so today the
number one is the food banks the social
one is giving it to
food banks for
communities in need
another one is composting or giving it
to livestock
and the third one
that's the least used is for energy
production and anaerobic uh digesters
and then
the big field of regenerative
agriculture regenerative agriculture is
the best term right now in
our industry i'm sure you have heard
about it there's nothing new about it
for you to know fyi
uh we just repackaged it it's something
that we used to do a long time ago
and the concept of regenerative
agriculture is to
have an agricultural system that works
with the ecosystem is that integration
between the ecosystem and the production
system
and normally the focus of regenerative
agriculture is tends to be
soil health but also the biodiversity
of
of the farm
and the input reduction so the reduction
of the use of
pesticides of all sorts
per
synthetic fertilizers so normally
synthetic
inputs um
in my years of experience um
what we have learned about pesticides
unfortunately is that the more research
out there
the more we know they're detrimental for
human and environmental health i never
heard of new studies that say oh that
chemical oh no no no no
no it's not so bad you can add it to
your coffee probably not never
normally is we knew it impacted one
species and then with more studies we
know that impacts other species and
other species and other species is a
linear relationship
so i'm not saying we need to eliminate
that but we need to
work for a system that works
for us
and for the ecosystem and not against us
and that's kind of the
the core of regenerative agriculture
and then as i mentioned the social
responsibility
produce is packed with people lots of
people in one field
many of them are my co-workers and um
let's say
there's room for improvement there
that's a room for improvement and then
so
we focus as an industry
in 2014
there was an article in the la times
that shocked our industry
it exposed the labor practices in our
fields
in a way that shook everything and so
the industry got their act together
and said okay this is a box we're
setting a bar we're not going to go do
this and then created the
the ethical charter
we host this our association hosts that
as the old charter
that charter
being proof but it just sets a good
baseline for practices that we will we
will never never never do
and
we need accountability there we need
transparency
and ensuring that people throughout our
industry are treated with dignity and
respect i know that sounds big but
he needed to be said spread that way
um and so we host we as an association
whole post that whole world and then
and then the an area of renewable and
alternative energy would also include uh
energy efficiency very important for
our
our farms
um and then
water i could spend
a whole day or a whole week talking
about water
water
i always say
it's almost philosophical
it's
the essence of life
it's everywhere we're so reliant on it
and then
we have so many issues with water
and what are those issues
most of our industry is
is space on the west coast in california
very
lots of problems with
with water
they need
their
water reduction and irrigation
efficiency of irrigation systems is core
however if you think of other places
like the east coast or other regions
that might not be the case
but with climate change
precipitations are changing
and the risk of erosion is increasing
and so erosion prevention is also key to
our work in water and also water quality
talked about all those inputs that we're
putting onto the field those go into the
aquifer and into the water that we all
drink and then there's so many organisms
that depend on that water and so water
quality is core to our work
and last but not least
carbon
carbon is um
i call carbon the new gold
we keep talking about carbon in
agriculture
carbon
is normally
we talk about it on the soil health
part of the conversation
so the healthier your soil
it tends to
retain carbon for a longer time so you
become a carbon sink i always say that
um
in our problem with climate change and
how we address
carbonizing our planet
we as humans get very very smart and
think that we're going to invent these
machines and take carbon from the
atmosphere
but i tell you that there's this
technology
that is the most powerful terminology
for carbon sequestration and is called
nature
and within nature is called soil
soils are such powerful carbon sinks and
the more we know about our soils and how
we sink the carbon the better for all of
us
and so in addressing climate change we
think about carbon
we think about but we also think about
greenhouse gases so those are
again
carbon dioxide
we hear about carbon dioxide a lot but
there's also methane
methane in our industry is mostly
produced through that waste that we
create
and then last but not least and i talked
to some of your faculty members here
my pet peeve
nitrous oxide
very very powerful greenhouse gas
under the radar
synthetic fertilizer
has a lot to do with it so if we can
improve
our fertilizer use if we could move to a
more organic type of fertilizer that as
i was told today
keeps that carbon in the soil so the
nitrogen and the carbon
keep the nitrogen together in the soil
and do not release it
much better for us to address our
decarbonization
um and
mitigating climate change
and
i just want to say thank you for
listening to me
but now i want to listen from you
because i'm sure you have very specific
questions for me
so
go ahead and ask me
yes so correct so uh thanks tomorrow
thanks for uh dealing with all the
technology issues this morning
um so one issue that comes up a lot for
sustainability is
um and a lot of
people advocate for more local and
regional food systems as one way of
addressing
a lot of the negative impacts of
agriculture
um how does the association view that i
mean you represent a lot of people a lot
of big companies and globally
but a lot of the you know start talking
about local regional could go down to
small scale producers so what's the
association's interaction
with that sort of system
so as an association i think that many
of our
our grower super companies um
grow in one place and ship everywhere so
that's kind of
their business model
for me uh when i think of sustainability
the numbers speak for themselves so
um
if you're if you're putting an equation
and you're looking at your carbon
footprint
the answer is there
immediately you don't have to think they
you know
deep that having more local production
it's better
for
carbon dioxide reduction
however you have to look at the whole
question right
you could have a local production that
has
really high yields i'm sorry really low
yields or is using a lot of inputs so i
think that
sustainability is using the whole
equation and
locally grown solves at least one part
of the english which is the
fuel part of it
so that's the way we look at it just
very
looking at some equation
um
thank you for talking today uh i was
just curious about how the association
um
helps growers meet these sustainability
goals like i think we're all aware that
of the things we should be doing but are
there any incentives to help people
reach these goals
more easily
so now the drivers of the conversation
is sustainability are the retailers the
retailers are big brands and they want
to differentiate themselves from one
another
with their sustainability requirement
they have come late to the game
but they really are speeding up and
they're really demanding a lot out of of
growers so
a lot of the
incentive for growers today is that you
won't be able to sell
if you don't meet these requirements
from these hours
you had a question sorry yes um and your
thank you so much for speaking to us in
your presentation you discussed a lot
about
produce
i have some questions about flora
culture
um
often times in well i have some
experience in a large commercial
greenhouse and oftentimes i saw that the
company i worked for was reluctant to
implement some sustainability practices
um because of some like incorrect
notions
how do we bridge the gap as scientists
with farmers like you you talked a
little bit about inspiration and i think
there's more inspiration in the world of
like produce and food
than there is in in floriculture like
are people interested in like
really organic petunias like is the how
how do we make people
in that industry
how do we make the sustainability sexy
for flowers like it's
a question so the floral industry for
the most part most of the
flowers sold in the u.s are grown in
colombia and ecuador
most of the flowers in pots are grown in
the u.s and canada why because you can't
import soil into the united states plain
and simple
and so
those are the big differences
in terms of sustainability
in my experience uh and i'm newer to
floral but
floral have gotten their act together
really well in creating standards for
sustainability
um in the field and so because they sell
to so many markets worldwide that's how
they have
um
improve
those in the us i don't know how do you
inspire them
um
and
i think my
my answer for inspiration is always um
and
you want to you want to produce in a way
that is more horribist with your
environment but not only with just the
environment even with other companies so
um
that's kind of the best it's just is
that a constant is that
constant improvement process
sustainability is always better it's not
a journey sorry it's not a destination
it's a journey
um
but yeah each person might have a
different um way of inspiring so
somebody else
how would you describe the pathway from
a novel
um sustainable farming practice to
actual implementation and acceptance by
the community
how does that happen
so
the novel practices come from
a myriad of faces some of them are
coming from universities
some of them are coming from there were
cultural companies that they have test
squads themselves and they're testing
new agronomic
practices
um
and that's how normally new advances are
introduced and some of some
some growers
through experience and through good
practices have been able to introduce
without having specific test spots just
regular regular fields
do you say it's more of a stepwise kind
of acceptance rather than
being and like being able to get the
information out there kind of
accelerates it would you say that's
accurate yeah it's
it's a step system and it's a it's an
industry that
is not
open to change
normally they said in their own ways
for the most part so it's really
reluctant
for the most part to change so it takes
a while to convince those growers wait a
minute if you do this this will happen
because many of them you know they they
have been growing for more than one
generation they know what they're doing
so they they take a
minute or two to accept new practices so
you had a question oh i was just gonna
piggyback on the floral thing because i
you walk into wagons and all the flowers
are
packaged in
at least one
layer of plastic if not two or more
and i've complained about it
it's it's horrible i mean you don't see
anything else in the produce it's quite
that bad you're absolutely right and
that is the biggest problem of the
floral industry they have done great
work at sustainability in the field and
a lot of in their standards focus
up on in the field practices
they're not talking about packaging and
their packaging is not recyclable so
they they have they have a big issue
there because
much more so than probes
requests about how you interface with
the members of the opponent's
association so do you like consult with
them on a one-on-one basis uh what if
a member of the association is a really
bad actor do they
say tomorrow go talk to these folks i
mean i guess i'm trying to understand
how
how you carry out your mission within
the produce association
so
what we have a sustainability council
within the association
and normally is composed of
sustainability professionals within each
company
and
um that's where the conversation the
bulk of the conversation is and then i
get a ton of one-on-ones um
right now
they're so excited
or tired of sustainability something
with sustainability so i get a lot of
one-on-one emails from
a company like we're trying to do this
we want to do that and it's a hot topic
for all of them but i try to
house them in the council so we can have
one voice and it's easier to manage for
sure
and
do you have a sorry do you have some
like really top priorities that the
council is sort of focused on i thought
what would be like the top two or three
things that you talk about that really
need to be addressed
in the industry because we're a new york
association or a new council and
right now what i'm working with the
council is to create that program within
the association so what i'm hearing from
the members
they want from us to help them with
definitions what is compostable
packaging what is regenerative
agriculture things like that you know so
help them with the definitions they want
training and education on practices in
the field
um but
i also they want us to represent them
globally and have a voice of the
industry and global institutions they
want us to um
support research that can help them with
sustainability
and
i think that i cover all of them you
weren't well those seven areas aren't
really there but this is the but we but
we the way we um
work so
we have the council and then we have
task forces for each one of those seven
areas because they're very technical and
very specific each one of them although
many of them as you could imagine
they're interrelated
there's a question about that yeah um
you talk a lot about your
the people that you communicate with in
companies
um and that it's hard to change their
mind because these
growers are set in their own way um and
then you also address a question about
incentive and said
actually there's relatively minimal
incentive from our side but more because
they want the name of sustainability and
the name of organic on their things
but does this not disproportionately
impact small-scale growers who can't
afford to
move away from the plastic because
they're trying to get the highest yield
out of the smallest area when being
you know in competition with massive
companies that have monocultures of
these floral crops or these vegetable
crops so
how are you trying to integrate these
small scale growers
that start out with less money maybe
start out with organics to try and
incentivize their
income when they're being sided with
these massive powerhouses that can
afford to lose acres and acres of these
props because they're not using plastic
or they're not spraying these pesticides
so how would you
in in this company make incentives for
those small-scale growers to want to be
sustainable as well because we're seeing
that these populations are not only
younger but they're wanting to be
greener and so when you say that these
these companies are stuck in their own
ways it's because it's the generation
above them but it's hard for these
younger growers to get into it so how do
you incentivize that
so one of the reasons a lot of these
companies are setting their own ways
that one they've been doing a
pretty good job for a long time so they
know they're doing well but and um
and another one
is because they have a lot of pressures
have immense pressures from outside so
it's hard for them to adopt new changes
because they
are afraid of that change and not all of
them so
i'm generalizing a little bit the
smaller growers
whether smaller growers are finding
and could find um is the niche markets
which they are and they're emerging as
well and as you said um
younger generations tend to be more
environmentally minded um
that seems to be a trend so
i can see
i mean
i don't know i can think of
farmers markets a few decades ago
to today
to
niche
agricultural products a few decades ago
versus today there's been a change in
that evolution and i think so some of
the smaller growers are finding those
niche markets that's how they are but
it's tough is
as you said you know
how to compete with the bigger ones um
although
some of the bigger ones are less nimble
and when something bad happens they
can't react as fast as smaller growers
so that's the advantage of the smaller
growers that flexibility and
adaptability to change and the bigger
ones
when things go bad
you're hearing
massive layoffs companies doing so bad
you know
um discarding bills etc reducing their
operations it's hard for them um but the
smaller ones can adapt to change better
you talked a little bit about one of the
seven like initiatives being labor
and um
a lot of these props that we discuss
like strawberries are very labor
intensive like migrant workers in
california threaten their kids like if
you don't do well in school you're gonna
have to work in the strawberry fields
but a lot of these props are like
inherently like you just have to crouch
over and like pick you like try not to
squish strawberry like
what what um can technology and policy
change do
to like advocate advocate for better uh
labor practices
labor practices have to change for sure
and
be better and policy has a lot of work
to do there to
be more vigilant
but
technology is doing a great work
there's a lot a lot a lot of investment
in
robots that can pick
um props the technology is in its infant
state right now
because
especially for fruits
to you know the human eye can detect
exactly you know the color of the fruit
when it's ripe and the texture because
you can feel it with your fingers so it
can beep at the right time that's really
really hard to develop the technology to
get there but they're working on it so i
would say in 10 years we're going to see
more robux in the fields substituting
humans
but there's great ways to go to make
humans have a better labor condition and
that's where cause
it tastes good
but california's been doing a lot of
work on that though how they treat there
and there have been a lot of laws that
that have changed it has gotten so much
better i think that
um they're not there yet but yeah
no but so so much better i mean that art
that article in 2014 just
you know
it just exploded and so
that
i feel i
i think that legislators saw the risk of
their industry sinking
and then they reacted
my fear is that we might have
another time bomb with other areas of
sustainability we don't want to be there
we need to be
ahead of the game that's what
my goal is that we don't have we don't
need to have a catastrophe like that
happening
in order for us to change
so returning back to the
pervasive plastic problem in the
industry um are there any breakthroughs
that you're particularly excited about
that are going to
um change the
or help mitigate the plastic problem
um well so i have the luxury to talk to
a lot of
really cool companies that are really
really interesting things with plastic
um
i see solutions in in two ways
one is we need to improve the
recyclability
of plastic so we could
and
that could buy us time
until we
find
better um materials
out there because right now
in produce we're asking a lot out of
those materials so if you think about an
agricultural field
it's
normally is picked in
in warm seasons
strong
um ultraviolet light from sun high
temperatures
and then has to be cool right away so
all of that is a lot to us out of um
a material so a lot of plastic
alternatives crumble
into pieces and i've seen them uh so
that's that's that's the challenge but i
have seen um a lot of the work is being
done in compostability
and
[Music]
right now the european union is asking
for reusability and that's going to be
extremely challenging for produce
because we have
and i didn't mention it here because i
talked about sustainability but food
food safety is
huge in our industry because we're
talking about human health we're talking
life or death if we don't uh perform
certain practices so
it's a tough it's a tough one but
they're good products pipeline
so we are just on time um if you'd like
to come up and maybe ask some more
questions um do you have a few minutes
or so
yes and then she's out to lunch
perfect thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu